[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's uh ask tom curran that question
the patriots insider
seven in ten with mac jones 10-7 with
cam newton if you ask patriots fans
they would happily well all right they
would rather see seven and ten with mack
jones but i don't think that there's any
planet on which
cam newton would extract more wins from
this team in 2021 than mack jones
oh really so do you think this is truly
open competition between these two
it very much truly is an open
competition and it's getting closer by
the day if it's not already a horse race
well what did you see last night that
would change somebody's opinion
well it's bill has put it out there
beginning with the draft that it's
camp's job camp's a starter and he kind
of reiterated that
a second time which i think was reading
off the cue cards at the beginning of
camp
but since then the patriots have divvied
up reps throughout
the training camp practices and then
they did the same thing yesterday and
what we saw last night is a complete
reflection date on what we're seeing on
the practice field
jones goes back reads the defense puts
his foot in the ground
decides where he's going to go with the
ball and puts it out on time and
accurately cam newton his forte is none
of those things forte is
moving with the ball a little bit
running a little bit throwing with great
pace
and every fourth or fifth throw dan you
end up saying
my god what was that
my god
in a bad way
yeah yeah exactly and matt jones is not
having any of those throws where you're
going oh my god how did he even do that
he throws in some tight windows and you
say wow that was that was really kind of
good to fit it in there but he's not
dropping a jaw either but also when
you're trying to plan this offense
and you're going okay we got a running
quarterback and then we have a pocket
quarterback
it's kind of hard to say hey our offense
kind of can morph into whatever we need
to have it morph into what are they
built for they built for mack jones
they're built for cam newton
when you look at i think a lot of people
would contend that they're built to run
the ball and be a bully because they
have the two tight ends and they have
like five very good running backs and
they have an offensive line that can
bang people around but i don't think any
team is built to have a guy who can be
an impediment to successfully throwing
the football and that's what what cam
sometimes is as you pointed out
johnny smith hunter henry nelson aguilar
kendall
kendrick bourne all these guys they
brought in
to throw the football to not to block
not to watch somebody run around
so
mac jones is going to extract more from
those investments than cam will be able
to
what did you make of belichick's
post-game demeanor
i thought he was upbeat i thought he was
you know kind of satisfied with what he
saw
in a lot of ways did you hear his answer
to the challenge question
i asked him why he didn't challenge a
completion to uh jacoby myers which was
clearly a completion yeah just didn't
feel like it
those are the things you say at 69.
i brought up the comparison that
belichick and greg popovich are similar
because they had their run they they are
great they're hall of famers you know
what among amongst the greats of their
sport
but
san antonio is not winning a
championship again
anytime soon and the patriots feel like
they're
a few years away
you buy into that comparison yeah it's
not unfair just the interesting thing
about football as opposed to basketball
not like i'm preaching to you any great
knowledge that you don't have is
a coach matters more in football
and
you can eliminate a lot of teams right
out of the shoots because they're
welcome the patriots were not a seven
and nine team last year they were a
three and 13 team and belichick was able
to have a
game plan for a quarterback who was
challenged as a thrower and a special
teams and he would be in game management
and win games like over san diego which
was a much more talented team like 43 to
nothing so when i look at belichick he's
now invested and he has the players
popovich might not ever have the players
again but the quarterback as important
as he is
he's not as important as a duncan
or or a lebron or a kawhi or jimmy
butler was last year
i wonder how tough it is to get free
agents with brady gone because brady
gave you that possibility of winning a
championship and you don't have that
that person right now
and it was going away a little bit
though at the end of brady's run here
that was an interesting thing because
there was an uncertainty around brady
you remember uh i think it was adam
humphries went to the tennessee titans
instead of coming to new england jared
cook he's like is grant coming back is
he not eventually signs with new orleans
instead
really the money talked this offseason
with belichick and once these guys get
in here there's still an aura to
belichick that they're honored to be in
the system
some guys aren't some guys play here and
like this guy stinks let me out of here
but
um i think this is going to be a really
interesting season dan i cannot imagine
this team not having double-digit wins
and they're going to be a lot better
than you think
the patriots gave gronk's number out is
that is this a big deal it's being made
into a big deal that somehow they're
supposed to retire gronk's jersey well
it was rasheed caldwell's number
okay
they gave it to crock okay but it was
ben coates number two you can't retire
them all and i think the patriots when
they
were kind of a moribund franchise for
about 40 years
they said okay we can retire bruce
armstrong and geno capiletti's and steve
nelson's numbers and no one will ever
miss him what are we going to do go
through all 100 of them well now i mean
you see a guy running around in 33 and
you're like oh it's not kevin [ __ ] i
wonder what they probably should have
retired
you can't retire them all in football
dan too many humans
yeah but gronk is the greatest receiver
you had in in team history
i yeah they just
they have not stood on ceremony too much
with it i mean even bledsoe's numbers
getting handed out i don't know when
that first got reissued but if if 12 got
handed to mac jones then we'd have a
real story yeah though that's what i
that was my next question if i'm mac
jones i just say look you think i'm
gonna be him why don't you just give me
his jersey
that would have been
a bold move
[Laughter]
why number 50 for mac jones in training
cam he does that with all the draft
picks he gives some numbers in the 50s
so the the first round of the first guy
gets 50 the the second guy selected gets
51 and then 52 and so forth so
raimondry stevenson the running back who
rumbled for 91 yards last night on a
touchdown um he had number 53 until
yesterday uh the matt damon fall out
where matt damon came on the show and
said that he doesn't root for the
patriots he you know he'll root for tom
brady uh what kind of repercussions were
felt in the northeast
as you might imagine i is a hollywood
guy anyway i mean
kid no one cares no one cares what matt
damon
is rooting for kid are you using your
accent there
yeah and i don't think when i affect it
it really works as well so but
what if mark wahlberg said it
boy i you know what those guys they know
where their bread's buttered
if they want to go to super bowls
whether it's tampa bay or new england
you you want to be make sure that you're
good with tom tommy tummy
great to see you how's morale
here at the house pretty good we're all
upbeat it's gonna be a warm weekend all
we have is the press conference with
bill it's already done
uh yeah
we're good here we're going to play some
golf all right well good to talk to you
again thank you tom all right
tommy curran the patriots insider